[Music]
this might look like a normal town in
Norway but it's far from it
Longyearbyen is the world's most
northern town it's not a town for the
faint-hearted
the Sun doesn't rise for four months of
the year but more importantly this small
settlement is at the forefront of
climate change so what's it like to live
here just over 2,000 people called
longer be in their home it's a small
coal mining town on Spitsbergen island
in Norway Starbird archipelago it's a
place where there are more snowmobiles
than residents more than 4,000 of them
can be parked up at any one time its
remote location means it's home to the
world's northernmost church ATM
post-office museum commercial airport
and university there are other strange
quirks because where it is there are no
roads outside the three main settlements
hence the popularity of snowmobiles if
you get old or sick and need care you
have to return to the mainland and if
you do die well you can't be buried here
there's just one small graveyard and
that stopped accepting bodies years ago
the permanently frozen ground the
permafrost stops bodies from decomposing
it's not a town for the faint-hearted
local neighbors include more than 3000
polar bears living around Svalbard
that's why all residents have to carry
and know how to use a high-powered rifle
end time the
the settlement so guns are essential how
about house cats well apparently not in
fact they're banned from Starbucks Oh
groundless they optic birds can be kept
safe it's not the place for you if
you're afraid of the dark either there's
no Sun for four whole months of the year
[Music]
but what's really disconcerting about
this town is the impact climate changes
having here is warming faster in spa bar
than anywhere else on the planet is next
to east fjord the ice fjord which hasn't
frozen over in ten years
the ocean is just too warm any glasses
that still reach the field are now
melting from beneath and of course from
above because the air is much warmer now
- as the ice melts it pushes up sea
levels around the world big cities from
Miami to Kolkata could be submerged by
the waves
this corner of the High Arctic is
supposed to be a desert but it's raining
more even in midwinter if the rain then
freezes it forms a layer of ice that
covers the plants reindeer that live on
the tundra can kick away snow but not
ice
[Music]
all that rain can trigger landslides on
the steep mountains that surround longer
bin there are houses at the foot of the
slope which are auto risk of major
avalanches as the snow conditions change
they've been evacuated it's like a ghost
town life in the Arctic has never been
easy
residents are used up I see temperatures
long dark winters and of course polar
bears
these are risks they can predict what
they're now struggling with is all these
new threats from the rapidly changing
climate
[Music]